[Applause]
welcome to swipe from leaves this week
we've traveled north to a city with tech
credentials to shout about and here's a
little taste of what's coming up on the
program I meet the tech entrepreneurs
who say being up north is better than
down south Thomas has a go on the mo DS
brand new million pound gadget and David
Beckham joins a number of other legends
in the latest installments of Pro
Evolution Soccer so that's all to come
over the next 10 minutes or so but
before then let's get a quick look at
some other tech stories that made
headlines this week Apple has unveiled
its new iPhone 10 but it'll cost just
short of a thousand pounds if you want
to get your hands on one available in
November it has no home button and uses
facial recognition to unlock itself you
me the humanoid robot worked as a
conductor alongside tenor Andrea Bocelli
to put on a display to mark the first
international festival of robotics in
Italy the machine was taught the
movements in rehearsals so the computer
could memorize the correct gestures
however it can't improvise so any
unexpected change in tempo from the
musicians would have been off-key and
guy played host to the tech industry's
leading players this week the sky tech
summit 2017 focused on the ways
technology is transforming the TV
experience and the media and
entertainment industry more than 300
people from tech and content companies
attended the event which included
interactive workshops and exhibitions
did you know Leeds
is where the UK's first free internet
service provider launched remember free
surf back in the 90s well Lisa's still
flying the tech slack today NHS digital
and Sky's Technology Centre are among
the bigger names here but there's a lot
going on so to get a good overview I
went to meet Stuart Clarke he's the man
behind the Leeds and digital festival
and I began by asking him what he thinks
Leeds tech industry does best oh it's a
number of things with you really well I
mean that health tech is a great example
you know we have 23% of the UK's health
tech professionals in Leeds
in London that's got more with 24% my
fraction just just ahead we're catching
up we've got an interested it'll in the
city's the city's largest digital
employer they built the NHS patient
records database are also big on data
again we have more data scientists in
Leeds
than anywhere else you are good at
selling the city is great there's also a
buzz around the startup scene here
according to Stewart Leeds has always
been a city of entrepreneurs right back
to the Industrial Revolution it's just
the tools are different now no biggie oh
you can get cheeky the 20-something
co-founder of jig talk are soon to be
released dating app that covers a
person's face until enough messages are
exchanged to reveal their photo
piece-by-piece is a graduate from one of
the city's universities here
he believes staying in Leeds has
benefited his startup you look at
professional Xbox and PlayStation
players more often than not they're at
the top of the leaderboard because they
know how to navigate the map and I feel
as though Leeds was the perfect size to
know inside out
after those three years or over so I
could then come out of my undergraduate
course and know what buttons to press a
familiar product doing well in Leeds is
cocoon a smart home security device that
we featured on swipe two years ago the
entrepreneurs behind it a firmly rooted
in the city and that may have made them
more attractive to some wealthy
investors down south what's the
conferring of the funding round and
really successful crowd cube campaign
since we last saw you
and whilst we really struggled finding
investment in liens which i think is
probably something that's worth noting
and kind of calling out and equally
because we were in Leeds I think that
made us a bit more of an interesting
company for people to invest in the movi
an interactive video hosting platform
for businesses who want to understand
more about their audiences has been here
for three years what are the drawbacks
the downsides to being based in Leeds we
don't seem to notice that men
I don't know if we're completely biased
come on a muscle pal we were having a
thing earlier and obviously there's the
slight rivalry with Manchester however
we've just done a collaboration with a
great company over in Manchester so even
even that works out well for us how can
you continue this tech boom in Leeds
right now I think I think the key thing
is to make sure we keep bringing the
right amount the talent through because
we've grown so much as a sector within
Leeds in terms of number of jobs number
of startups some of the bigger companies
that are growing and what we've seen
over the last couple years is close
collaboration between the digital sector
in the city and the universities so we
see more graduates staying in this city
after the finish their studies and we're
seeing people come in from all around
the country because the see Leeds is a
great place to not only to work with
good salaries in the digital sector but
also to live now back in London this
week one of the world's biggest arms
fairs got underway there's been some
controversy surrounding the defense and
security equipment international event
but it's a given that modern innovation
has major implications for the
battlefield so Thomas went to see what
we're going to show this week companies
and armed forces from around the world
invaded East London for the DSE eye
defense and security equipment
international it's the largest fair of
its kind in the world and has drawn much
controversy since it began but we'll get
to that first swipe got hands-on with
one of the stars of the show the t7 bomb
disposal robots so it looks relatively
complicated but I'm sure it's not it's
actually not if you just lift up that
handle yeah and you can push the grey
button there under your middle finger
soon 56 of these robots will be in the
hands of the mo D after the manufacturer
was awarded a multi-million pound
contract they will allow soldiers to get
up-close with explosives while actually
staying well out of harm's way
right right so that is absolutely the
haptic feedback so there are sensors in
the fingers and when they make contact
with something they send that as
feedback to you as the user so you can
actually feel what the robot is doing
and that definitely helps an operator
when they don't have a system sitting
right next to them like we do it helps
them when they're in their camera view
and they only have that to D they can
you have actually feel that sensation
and know what they're doing beyond this
primary duty these gadgets can be
refitted to perform chemical cleanups
provide intelligence or even engage in
SWAT missions all no deals are actually
made during DSCI it's a chance for
exhibitors to show off their latest
innovations and souped-up hardware even
in times of relative peace defense
companies are often found at the
forefront of technological innovation
some of the tech on show here could
easily be put in the hands of police
forces the way we focused on facial
recognition is for the real-world
environments let's be able to do it on a
camera on a crowd of people who aren't
necessarily looking directly at the
camera so we have cameras installed in
the front of this car yeah so this is a
demonstration vehicle we have between
five and eight cameras now live covertly
installed within the vehicle all hidden
all hidden in real-time we're actually
coming up on the screen over there yet
you can see as displayed a lifetime with
captions above our heads and the exact
watch list and interest details of the
person on a live video suite the UK is
the world's third biggest defense
exporter making an event like this
highly controversial many view it as a
marketplace for war protesters have
flanked the building all week but
however you see it this event is big
business an all-in-one showcase for the
UK's and the world's top military tech
Thomas Newton Sky News time for some
virtual fun now and Lucie
and having a go on some of the latest
video game releases so that you can
decide which ones are worth buying and
which are worth bidding here she is
destiny 2 is the eagerly anticipated
shared world shooter /part MMO slash
part first-person shooter from Bungie
those who fled are being hunted and
those who should have to remain have
been executed so the thing that's so
great about destiny is you can play it
on your own but you can also play with
your friends as this shared world so you
and millions of other players around the
globe can be playing in the same world
and people just want to drop in and you
can team up together to take down bosses
and enemies but the thing that really
keeps me engaged with destiny and keeps
me wanting to go back and play it it's
the loot system so obviously every time
you take out a big wave of enemies
you're gonna get some really good loot
for it and then you can kind of show it
off to your friends you keep popping in
and out of the game it's a big big
release for this quarter and honestly
you'll have seen the hype around it and
it is very very good it basically builds
on the original and improves it in
almost every single way nack 2 is
another big release from this week you
kind of play this little character
called nack he's made up of all these
crazy particles which is actually very
impressive if you take a closer look at
it but you basically kind of brawl your
way through these levels there's
platforming sections there are puzzles
to solve
it's very cutesy it's more for kids and
you can play in co-op which is really
cool if you have like a kid that you
want to introduce to video games but
slowly so nak is a good choice for that
but what's also cool about it is that
not only is that kind of normal-sized he
can grow to be like this gigantic knack
or he can shrink down and you have to
change sizes to sort of solve some of
the puzzles which is really quite cool
so if there's a younger game in your
life definitely try and pick up next
[Music]
it's that time of the year again where
FIFA fans and Pro Evo fans battle it out
Pro Evolution Soccer 18 is out this week
so we're gonna be talking about that one
as with every iteration at these games
there's a lot of small improvements that
you really appreciate if you're a
longtime fan things like closed ball
control AI all been improved and
tinkered with ever so slightly to make
the game that much more enjoyable you
can of course play online play with your
friends like co-op but on top of that
you know FIFA always gets like the big
licenses but there are some very
familiar faces in Pro Evo a team David
Beckham is the big star this year and
for some reason so is Usain Bolt's but
the tide is always changing between
which one's better if we were talking
about blue firm Pro Evo so definitely
give both of them a try there's a free
demo available right now for Pro Evo if
you want to give it a whirl before the
game comes out
well that's it from us here in leaves
join us again for more swipe next week
and in the meantime follow us on Twitter
app tiny white thank you for watching
bye bye
[Applause]
you